[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
berichte und claus kleber
guten abend wer noch beweis dafür
brauchte wie grundlegend sich
machtverhältnisse verschoben haben der
bekamen heute europa hatte gebettelt
dass us truppen in kabul noch ein
bisschen länger die stellung halten die
taliban bestanden darauf dass sie
pünktlich verschwinden amerika musste
sich entscheiden und entschied sich für
die taliban die konnten ihre forderung
mit drohungen befeuern und rannten in
wahrheit offene türen ein bei einem
kriegsmüden amerikanischen präsidenten
der seinem müde gewordenen volk kein
opfer mehr zumuten darf und so
bestimmten gotteskrieger vom hindukusch
beschlüsse eines virtuellen g7-gipfel
der angeblich mächtigsten
industriestaaten anne gellinek berichtet
die franzosen haben es schon am morgen
geahnt und konsequenzen gezogen ab
donnerstag also schon ab übermorgen
wollen sie ihre evakuierungsflüge aus
kabul stoppen wenn die amerikaner den
flughafen nicht länger als bis zum
monatsende absichern es ist ein weiteres
eingeständnis der europäer dass ohne die
militärmacht der amerikaner nichts läuft
wenn die usa gehen ist das retten zu
ende
ohne die vereinigten staaten von amerika
können wir zum beispiel die anderen die
evakuierungsaktion nicht weiterführen
das muss man ganz klar wissen joe biden
weiß das und hat trotzdem anders
entschieden auf dem g7 video treffen der
großen 7 industriestaaten haben der
brite johnson der franzose makro und
angela merkel den amerikaner bearbeitet
offenbar umsonst
ja sie haben recht es gibt keine
änderung am zeitplan die mission wird
ende des monats abgeschlossen sein
der mächtigste mann der welt sitzt
ebenfalls in der falle noch gestern hat
der fce chef william burns nach kabul
geschickt und mit der nummer zwei der
taliban zu verhandeln doch die ließen
sich nicht erweichen die ausländer
sollen verschwinden die afghanen dagegen
im land bleiben die europäer müssen sich
nun auf die einsicht von islamisten
verlassen
kindisch wir als je sieben sätzen den
taliban die bedingung dass sie den
menschen die das land verlassen wollen
auch über den 31
august hinaus sichere wege aus dem land
garantieren
dabei wissen alle sieben jungen diesen
tisch sitzen dass sie in afghanistan
wenig bis gar keinen einfluss mehr haben
nicht bei der sicherung des flughafens
und nicht bei der gestaltung der zukunft
des landes china pakistan indien
russland die wichtigsten player saßen
heute nicht mit am tisch der russische
aussenminister kündigt schon mal an dass
sein land nicht mitspielt
die amerikaner haben sich anscheinend
vorgestellt dass sie wenn sie abgezogen
sind einen teil ihrer truppen und des
geräts in den nachbarländern
stationieren um afghanistan beschließen
zu können wenn es sich schlecht benimmt
die amerikaner werden sich wohl
tatsächlich in sieben tagen vom
flughafen kabul zurückziehen einfacher
wird dadurch nichts
während die usa und europa noch um ihre
antwort ringen bestimmen die taliban was
in afghanistan geschieht mit den land
und mit den menschen die vergangenheit
der taliban ist da eindeutig ihre
aktuellen auftritte sind es nicht da
prallen glaubwürdige berichte von
gräueltaten auf inszenierungen eine art
taliban 2.0 port beobachtet dass es war
nur ein kurzer satz aber bei vielen
afghanen dürfte ja panik ausgelöst haben
wir werden afghanischen bürgern nicht
erlauben auszureißen wir brauchen diese
menschen für den aufbau des landes er
sagt es beiläufig eine randnotiz die
taliban schließen die tore es folgen
wolkige wohlfühl versprechen
professionell inszeniert im feinen
rahmen ohne kalaschnikows dezent im ton
und fernab der realität beispiel
pressefreiheit
wir verfolgen niemanden wir haben ja
eigens eine amnestie angekündigt es gibt
auch keine listen mit namen die wir
suchen alles was wir wollen ist frieden
und versöhnung
eine journalistin darf fragen ich werde
aber zu hause in herat verfolgt
vielleicht gibt es da im einen oder
anderen fall private vorfälle dem gehen
wir natürlich nach aber sie können als
presse beruhigt und in sicherheit auch
in herat arbeiten
nachfrage entschuldigung ihre
zusicherungen sind nichts wert
journalisten verlassen das land
wir sorgen für sicherheit auch für die
medien sie sind ja auch ohne
schwierigkeiten hierher gekommen
für sicherheit solle demnächst auch
wieder reguläre polizei sorgen so die
ankündigung wie wenig sicher das land
für viele taliban gegner in afghanistan
ist beklagte die hochkommissarin für
menschenrechte heute in genf zu
den menschenrechtsverletzungen gehören
standrechtliche hinrichtungen von
zivilisten und mitgliedern der
afghanischen sicherheitskräfte sowie
einschränkungen der rechte von frauen
frauenrechte auch ein thema bei dem der
taliban-sprecher schöne worte findet
wegen der sicherheitslage sollten frauen
dort nicht arbeiten gehen da sind ja
viele bewaffnete unterwegs die wissen
nicht wie man sich frauen gegenüber
richtig verhält deswegen ist es sicherer
für frauen wenn sie erst einmal zu hause
bleiben
inschallah so gott will
über 20 jahre waren es wahrscheinlich
millionen afghanen die ihre hoffnungen
darauf gesetzt hatten dass das was wird
was die so genannte weltgemeinschaft
ihnen versprochen hatte der schock des
elften september hatte den versprechen
so eine aura der ernsthaftigkeit gegeben
die sich nicht erst jetzt aber jetzt
endgültig in luft auflöst diejenigen die
daran glaubten haben ihr leben aufs
spiel gesetzt sowie die bürgermeisterin
einer stadt außerhalb von kabul sie
stand mit sicherheit auf den todeslisten
taliban wir sind froh dass die letzte
nacht in deutschland gelandet ist ein
netz aus einflussreichen menschen hat
das möglich gemacht katrin eigendorf hat
ihre geschichte über die jahre verfolgt
und stellt so eva gaspar kurz vor
eine afghanin die auffällt tarife
havarie ist die einzige frau unter
männern und sie ist die chefin als
bürgermeisterin der provinzmetropole mai
dann schießt sie angetreten korruption
zu bekämpfen sich für frauenrechte
einzusetzen
wir begleiten sie die bereits als 26
jährige international zur
hoffnungsträgerin für ein modernes
afghanistan geworden ist doch der mut
hat seinen preis nur mit bewaffnetem
begleitschutz kann sich zur ifa davari
fortbewegen die einschusslöcher in der
heckscheibe erinnern an einen von
mehreren anschlägen die sie überlebt hat
dass die taliban nie wieder an der macht
beteiligt werden dafür tritt sie trotz
aller gefahren immer wieder öffentlich
ein und ihre enttäuschung ist groß als
die usa mit den islamisten einen
friedensvertrag schließen wir treffen
uns im juni in kabul wieder kurz bevor
die letzten deutschen soldaten das land
verlassen haben ihren job als
bürgermeisterin hat sie aufgegeben mit
dem vormarsch der taliban sei er zu
gefährlich geworden erzählt sie mir doch
sie will weiterkämpfen und hat eine neue
aufgabe gefunden sie arbeitet für das
verteidigungsministerium und kümmert
sich um die familien von soldaten die
getötet wurden so wie ihr eigener vater
der nur wenige monate zuvor von den
taliban erschossen wurde wenig später
das ahnen wir bei unserem gespräch noch
nicht wird kein platz mehr sein in
afghanistan für frauen wie sie doch
tarifa gefahr wird ihre vision weiter
verfolgen jetzt aus der ferne
wir erreichen tarifa wir jetzt an einem
sicheren ort in düsseldorf in
deutschland guten abend dorthin
denke ich danke ihnen vielmals guten sie
den triumph der taliban erlebt waren sie
so überrascht wie die politik fast
überall im westen
wir waren genauso überrascht wie alle
anderen wir waren genauso schockiert
oder wahrscheinlich noch schockiert als
alle anderen und wir haben einen starken
schmerz empfunden den uns andere
menschen sicher nicht so
nachempfinden können
es war wirklich hart
und was besonders schrecklich war war
dass es nur ein paar stunden brauchte um
den 20-jährigen kampf vieler vieler
menschen zunichte zu machen mit dem
kampf vor allem jahr afghanischen frau
und frauen wie ich frauen meiner
generation die afghanischen frauen
mussten sich in der geschichte an jedes
regime und jede neue situation im land
immer anpassen jetzt haben wir frauen 20
jahre lang hart gekämpft wir haben
gekämpft und wir haben viel erreicht wir
haben allen gezeigt dass wir keine
feinde für afghanistan sind für seine
kultur für seine islamischen regeln und
für seine tradition und wir haben etwas
erreicht und plötzlich kam es nun zu
diesen ereignissen und all das hat
großes chaos verursacht und es bedeutet
für uns einen großen verlust und wir
stehen sozusagen wieder am anfang das
war ganz furchtbar für uns wie sich
sicher jeder vorstellen kann
haben sie inzwischen eine erklärung
gefunden wie das geschehen konnte dass
so etwas so lange im verborgenen blieb
und dann so über nacht seinen triumph
feiern konnte
wir hätten auf jeden fall niemals
erwartet dass die taliban in kabul
einmarschieren würden aber sie haben
kabul erobert während sie in den
sozialen medien verkündeten dass sie
nicht nach kabul folgen würden und
niemand wusste dass sie bereits überall
in kabul waren dass sie überall waren
gleichzeitig war der fall von kabul
etwas das sich niemand hätte vorstellen
können
für die aktuelle krise in afghanistan
gebe ich allen die schuld dem
afghanischen präsidenten den
afghanischen politikern der
internationalen gemeinschaft den
internationalen politikern den medien
den bürgern vor ort alles hat schuld
alle vielleicht bin sogar ich selbst mit
schuld denn wir waren nicht da
[Musik]
als das land uns brauchte wir waren
nicht bereit das zu tun was wirklich
nötig gewesen wäre
wir haben uns nicht gegen das
ausgesprochen was um uns herum geschah
wir haben uns einfach
zurückgelehnt sozusagen und passiv
zugeschaut
das ist der grund warum sich die
situation im land jetzt so entwickelt
hat es ist schwer das zu akzeptieren
aber jeder hat seinen teil dazu
beigetragen dass die errungenschaften
der letzten 20 jahre jetzt zerstört
wurden um es klar zu sagen die schuld
liegt leider hauptsächlich bei der
internationalen gemeinschaft
es wurde immer gesagt
wir haben milliarden von dollar
ausgegeben ja sie haben milliarden von
dollar ausgegeben das stimmt was wir in
den 20 jahren erreicht haben das hat
viele menschenleben gekostet das hat zu
blutvergießen gefühl dass wurde mit dem
preis
des kampfes der menschen vor ort
erreicht
und nun war das alles praktisch umsonst
und als die internationale gemeinschaft
uns
beiseite stehen sollte als wir sie am
meisten brauchten die sie uns im stich
und
fing an mit diesem abzug sie sprechen so
als ob sie fürchteten dass das das ende
der geschichte ist dass diese episode
der taliban jetzt für die nächsten
jahrzehnte wieder neu auflebt
nein das glaube ich nicht
wenn die taliban bleiben wollen dann
müssen sie einige realitäten vor ort
akzeptieren sie müssen mich akzeptieren
sie müssen in meiner generation
akzeptieren sie müssen die veränderungen
akzeptieren dies in afghanistan gegeben
hat die afghanische frau ist nicht mehr
die frau von 2001 oder vielleicht 1997
oder 98 die afghanische frau ist keine
frau die einfach im hintergrund bleibt
wir werden nicht zurückweichen wir
werden nicht aufgeben wir haben uns
immer sehr gut an neue situation
angepasst aber das bedeutet nicht
dass wir das unrecht gegen unsere
generation gegen meine generation
hinnehmen werden
also das sag ich ganz ganz klar der
appell einer mutigen frau dankeschön
safari und alles gute
vielen dank
wir haben unser gespräch am frühen abend
aufgenommen tarifa gawhary hat schlimme
tage und eine harte reise hinter sich
vor allem aber wollten wir uns mehr zeit
lassen als unsere sendung platz hat es
los hier aber ihr ganz zuzuhören online
zdf heute.de die politisch
verantwortlichen auch in berlin müssen
sich nun fragen und fragen lassen was da
so katastrophal falsch gelaufen und was
nun zu tun ist ein bericht über den
traurigen stand der dinge und argumente
von andreas künast
stein sicht anflug so nennt es der
bundeswehr pilot möglichst lange in
sicherer höhe bleiben und erst kurz vor
der landebahn sehr schnell sinken auf
den flughafen kabul das tor zur hölle
die bundeswehr filmt diese aufnahmen es
gibt keine journalisten hier keine
bodenkontrolle nur notlösungen nur not
ausladen und einsteigen bei laufenden
motoren sechs besatzungen vier flieger
schon bald wird einer der letzte sein
amerikaner beim 31 8 bleiben dann löst
das natürlich auch
einen gewissen prozess aus für den dann
die planungen auch entsprechend
zu machen sind und das tun wir auch aber
ich bitte auch um verständnis dass wir
da nicht sehr ins detail gehen der
gewisse prozess heißt rückzug ende
katastrophe ohne den schutz der 6.000 us
soldaten muss die bundeswehr aufgeben
während noch tausende zehntausende
verzweifelt versuchen evakuiert zu
werden lässt berlin heute endgültig
wissen wir werden nicht alle retten
können für den ärger ja die wut auf
dieses geständnis der bundesregierung
steht stellvertretend hauptmann markus
grotjahn der in kundus stationiert war
und ein netzwerk für ortskräfte
gegründet hat wir sind überwältigt von
fassungslosigkeit weil
regierungsparteien und politiker die
warnungen missachtet die hinweise und
lösungsmöglichkeiten ignoriert die
verantwortlichkeiten abgeschoben haben
und bis heute in die eigenen verfahren
und handlungen loben das gestern die
minister für verteidigung und für
auswärtiges persönliche konsequenzen
nicht ausgeschlossen haben weckt heute
interpretations bedarf ich trage die
politische verantwortung für alles was
im auswärtigen amt geschieht natürlich
auch insbesondere für die fehler die
gemacht werden normalerweise müsste es
doch umgehend auch personelle
schlussfolgerung geben aber wir haben
leider in dieser region eine kultur der
verantwortungslosigkeit maß und kramp
karrenbauer wollen über die konsequenzen
sprechen sobald sich die akute
bedrohungslage entschärft im moment ist
das gegenteil der fall wir haben signal
da sowohl aus den
amerikanischen quellen wie aber auch aus
den eigenen einschätzungen dass es
zunehmend zu selbstmordattentätern kommt
die in die stadt ein sieg aus dem
bereich des das nimmt jetzt zu und führt
zu erhöhten vorsichtsmaßnahmen für die
menschen die sich auf deutschland
verlassen haben hat ein grausamer
countdown begonnen in sieben tagen ist
die us-armee weg die bundeswehr
vermutlich schon früher das tor aus der
hölle schließt sich
nachrichten nun von kaiser berichtet
schauen wir auf die korona anlage vor
dem hintergrund steigender
infektionszahlen hat hamburg ein
sogenanntes zweig optionsmodell
beschlossen damit haben veranstalter
fitnessstudios oder gastronomen ab
samstag die wahl entweder sie lassen
auch gäste reihen die 2 getestet sind
nicht aber geimpft oder gewesen dann
müssen sie sich weiter an alle chor ohne
auflagen halten oder sie verwehren
dieser gruppe den eintritt dann werden
sie von einigen beschränkungen befreit
zb können sie dann mehr gäste empfangen
an der technischen universität darmstadt
gibt ein mutmaßlicher giftanschlag
rätsel auf dort ermittelt eine
40-köpfige mordkommission nach dem
gestern sieben menschen
vergiftungserscheinungen aufgewiesen
hatten ein student schwebte zeitweise in
lebensgefahr
alle betroffenen hatten in der
hochschule lebensmittel zu sich genommen
zum beispiel milch oder wasser aus
behältern inzwischen wurde darin eine
chemikalie nachgewiesen um welche es
sich handelt sagte der ermittler aus
taktischen gründen nicht die
hintergründe sind noch unklar
mindestens 180 tote und
milliardenschäden das ist die hochwasser
bilanz in deutschlands westen nun
bestätigt eine studie internationaler
wissenschaftler dass solche
flutkatastrophen tatsächlich mit dem
klimawandel zusammenhängt ohne ihn
würden solche unwetter statistisch alle
2000 jahre auftreten durch die bisherige
erderwärmung seien sie in unserer region
bereits alle 400 jahre zu erwarten auch
die intensität nehme immer weiter zu
nach dem lokführerstreik hat die bahn
für morgen einen weitgehend normalen
zugverkehr angekündigt noch in der nacht
sollen personal und züge an die
richtigen bahnhöfe gebracht werden heute
sorgt der arbeitskampf noch für probleme
pendler und urlauber müssen ausfälle und
verspätungen hinnehmen
so fahren von den fernzügen nur 30
prozent bis 2 uhr ließ die gdl noch
streiten
eine gute und eine schlechte nachricht
gab es vom statistischen bundesamt auf
der einen seite springt in deutschland
die konjunktur wieder an auf der anderen
seite verbucht der staat das zweit
größte defizit seit der
wiedervereinigung die pandemie hat
enorme löcher gerissen wie ist das alles
zum bewährten frank bethmann in
frankfurt na ja die gute nachricht geht
nicht ohne die schlechte das hing
zusammen denn hätte die bundesregierung
in der größten corona note im letzten
jahr nicht so entschlossen geld in die
hand genommen die wirtschaft wäre
vermutlich noch längst nicht wieder auf
kurs mit der schuldenaufnahme
finanzierte der stadt nämlich vor allem
die korona überbrückungshilfen für
unternehmen den kauf von impfstoffen und
schutzausrüstungen und das
kurzarbeitergeld an millionen von
beschäftigten die vorübergehend durch
die pandemie nicht arbeiten konnten das
abfedern der staat ist war teuer 81
milliarden euro beträgt das aktuelle
defizit und das - droht weiter zu
wachsen denn corona ist noch nicht
vorbei gleichzeitig warten weitere
milliarden herausforderungen auf den
fiskus nur ein beispiel die marode
infrastruktur 3000 brücken müssen in
deutschland modernisiert werden zudem
gilt fast jeder fünfte autobahnkilometer
inzwischen als sanierungsbedürftig
der staat muss deutlich mehr investieren
fordern ökonomen seit vielen jahren und
haben dabei nicht nur den schlechten
baulichen zustand im kopf zur ganzen
wahrheit gehört vielmehr auch ohne
schuldenmachen kaum noch wachstum diese
gleichung immer mehr schulden für immer
mehr wachstum ist auf dauer leider eine
ziemlich und gesunde rechnung dank an
die börse frank der chef der
bundesagentur für arbeit scheele warnt
vor einem massiven mangel an
arbeitskräften durch den demografischen
wandel nehme die zahl der potenziellen
beschäftigten schon in diesem jahr um
fast
150000 ab sagte er der süddeutschen
zeitung in den kommenden jahren werde es
noch viel dramatischer daher brauche es
eine gezielte zuwanderung von 400.000
menschen pro jahr außerdem müsse man auf
qualifizierung setzen
mit den rolling stones hat der
rockgeschichte geschrieben bis ins hohe
alter stand er mit ihnen auf der bühne
nun ist der musiker charlie watts
gestorben seit 1963 war der schlagzeuger
ruhepol und rhythmisches fundament der
stores
aber auch mit eigenen projekten ging auf
tour verlor seine große liebe zum jazz
die fachwelt zählte ihn zu den besten
roman überhaupt charlie watts wurde 18
japans hauptstadt tokio ist offiziell im
corona notstand und mit einem jahr
verspätung mit zögern und zweifeln am
ende heute trotzdem noch einmal
gastgeberin für athletinnen und athleten
aus 160 nationen einen monat nach den
wettbewerben der klassischen olympiade
bekommen die besten der sportler innen
mit behinderung ihre spiele und ihre
glänzend und eröffnungsfeier stefanie
schöne bauen berichtet davon
kraft finden mutig sein hoffnung
die eröffnungsfeier der paralympics
zeigt ein nachdenkliches japan sanfte
töne
und eines das so energiegeladen ist dass
es das wilde bunte vielfältige und
inklusive japan zeigt ein land das
elektrisieren will mitreißend verspielt
auffordernd inmitten dieser corona
geprägten zeit zuschauer gibt es keine
doch die vorfreude schmälert das nicht
auch nicht der deutschen fahnenträger
michael teuber und mareike müller ich
fand auch gerade in der show sehr gut
die inklusion transportiert sehr viele
verschiedene sportler wurden involviert
mit verschiedenen behinderungen
mit den einschränkungen mit prothesen im
rollstuhl und sowohl in der show als
auch in eben im transport der
olympischen flamme und das war eben
besonders schön renault team ist einer
von 133 deutschen athleten ehrt uns
handyaufnahmen geschickt ein blick
hinter die kulissen aus dem
paralympischen dorf mit seiner combo
mannschaft abgeschottet von den
steigenden corona fällen in japan
die eröffnungsfeier noch wenige stunden
für uns beginnt jeder tag erstmal mit
einem contest und der und jetzt wird das
noch ein bisschen geschluckt und dann
kann es losgehen
die stimmung ist vor allem euphorisch
auf dem weg zur eröffnungsfeier
[Musik]
sie können draußen dafür sind voller
vorfreude als gucke mal
abgestimmt also dann aufgeht
wow
die sportlerinnen und sportler haben
sich seit fünf jahren auf diesen tag
vorbereitet gehofft und gebangt dass die
paralympische flamme wirklich wieder
brennt und die spiele beginnen
ich habe die ganze zeit gänsehaut und
echt eine super gelegenheit jetzt hier
auch dabei zu sein und
alles erfüllt was man sich erträumt hat
aber grandios einfach nur phänomenal
trotz masken und corona der tag heute
gehört den 4400 athletinnen und athleten
die so hart für diesen moment trainiert
haben
einen alten baum verpflanzt man nicht
heißt es und trotzdem wagen einige
senioren den schritt und ziehen zu ihren
kindern um nicht allein zu sein meistens
eine schöne absicht aber dafür müssen
gleich zwei manchmal sogar drei
generationen ihre unabhängigkeit aufs
spiel setzen oder gleich aufgeben
gleichzeig die 37° -reportage welche
schönen momente aber auch
herausforderungen das zusammenrücken der
generationen mit sich bringt das kommt
hier gleich und um fünf nach zwölf von
china sind gibt im jahr auf den
aktuellen stand eben heute journal
update
[Musik]
guten abend das ist so besonders dass
ich ihnen es unbedingt zeigen muss denn
morgen wird es in abrede dass es im
norden island bis zu 27 grad geben nicht
in reykjavik da fällt regen bei nur 14
grad aber kuranyi hat morgen den
hitzerekord es ist da viel wärmer als
zum beispiel in oslo in stockholm berlin
in dublin oder in london und dahinter
steckt das hoch ghana und das tief mit
das hoch gaia bringt nämlich diese warme
luft aus südlichen gefilden nach island
das tief nick allerdings wird jetzt die
lücke füllen die das hoch jetzt lässt
und bringt uns neuen regen und sehr
wechselhaftes kühles wetter heute nacht
ist es meist klar und so sinken die
temperaturen verbreitet auf einstellige
9 bis 3 grad in einigen
mittelgebirgstälern reicht es vielleicht
sogar schon für den ersten bodenfrost
morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
meist um die 20 grad und zwischen
frankfurt und basel wird es bei 23 bis
25 grad noch etwas wärmer der tag
beginnt erstmal sehr freuen sich mit
viel sonnenschein aber dann kommt das
tief nick heranbringt wolken mit und
spätestens nachmittags beginnt es dann
in norddeutschland auch zu regnen dabei
nimmt der wind zu an der ostsee ist das
ein kräftiger westwind an der nordsee
ein kräftiger nordwestwind und mit
dieser nordströmung wird es von tag zu
tag immer kühler uns erwarten kräftige
schauer zum teil sogar gewitter und es
wird tatsächlich von tag zu tag so kalt
dass wir am samstag dann nur noch
temperaturen von 13 bis 19 grad haben
guten abend